يا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
برصاصه اصابته في القلب واستشهد على اثرها
في مدينه رام الله بالضفه الغربيه الحكومه
الفلسطينيه تطالب المجتمع الدولي وامريكا
باشباري اسرائيل على وقف انتهاكاتها وتعد
لمشروع قرار الامم يعتبر الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه بالقدس والضفه الغربيه
استمرار للاحتلاف عمران خان نرحب بطلب
الحكومه الباكستانيه تشكيله لجنه فضائيه
للتحقيق في محاوله اغتياله ويجدد مطالبته
باستقاله رئيس الحكومه ومسؤولين اخرين
لتتمكن اللجنه من التحقيق بشكل مستقل في
حين بحثت الحكومه الخيارات القانونيه
لمقاضاه عمران خان بسبب اتهامه مسؤولينا
حكوميين بتهمه التخطيط
رغم اتفاقي اطلاق النار مقتل سته مدنيين
بينهم طفلان وامراه واصابه 75 في قذف
للقوات النظام السوري على مخيمات النازحين
بمنطقه كفر جالس غرب مدينه ادلب شماليه
سوريا الدفاع المدني يقول ان قوات النظام
السوري استخدمت صواريخ محمله بقنا
بالعقديه محرمه دوليا بعد موجه تسريح شملت
فريق حقوق الانسان في تويتر المفوض الاممي
لحقوق الانسان يدعو الى الناس بضمان
الالتزام بمعايير حقوق الانسان في الشركه
وسجدنا بشان عزمي ماسك تحويله تويتر الى
منصه لتحقيق دخل من المحتوى خاصه بعد
اطلاقه خدمه الاشتراك الشهري للحصول على
العلامات الزرقاء